all right joe biden didn't say the words
china or russia
one time during today's speech before
the u.n general assembly but he did
mention the word climate
a lot
15 times for those keeping score at home
biden's climate agenda is aggressive but
it won't succeed unless he gets china
the world's top polluter on board
and who did he charge with such a
monumental task well john kerry of
course america's favorite jet flying
parasailing metal tossing swift boating
gold digging flip-flopping son of a gun
isn't that the best graphic you've ever
seen i'm pointing in the wrong direction
there it is it sort of says it all right
there on your screen you see john kerry
he's a man people take very seriously
when he tells coal miners to make solar
panels oh they listen and when he
travels to paris he always brings james
taylor with him
and when he travels around the world he
always puts the environment first
it's the only choice for somebody like
me
who is traveling the world to win this
battle
i negotiated the paris accords i
negotiated with president xi to bring
president xi to the table so we could
get paris the time it takes me to get
somewhere i can't sail across the ocean
i have to fly to meet with people and
get things done i'm not going to be put
on the defensive i love that banner i'm
allowed to fly private i'm important
and when he does happen to fly public he
always wears a mask except for all those
times that he doesn't but for some
reason he's having a tough time getting
the communist chinese to listen to him i
wonder why that is maybe because he's a
weak ineffectual hypocrite incapable of
strong arming the chinese into doing
anything
but maybe it's also because he's
compromised by chinese money as i
mentioned just a moment ago
according to a new report his wife
ketchup queen teresa hines has at least
a million bucks tied up in a hedge fund
that specializes in get this
chinese government controlled
investments
now we know it's just a fraction of
their family's massive inherited wealth
but it's a bad look especially when he's
trying and of course failing to muscle
the red chinese toward carbon neutrality
maybe it's time old johnny hang it up
and parasail off into the sunset it's
beautiful
and maybe you can let anthony blinken
and his baby bjorn
take over for him just a
show of intimidation joining me now
raymond arroyo
fox news contributor
raymond you know we knew he was
ineffective but we didn't know he was
counting on state-owned businesses to
line his pockets a little bit more
yeah well they'll take that climate deal
with a slight side of conflict of
interest the hinds will uh look theresa
heinz carey she's got up to maybe five
million dollars invested in this chinese
run hedge fund and i learned today pete
you know i'd read those long hunter
biden emails from the laptop turns out
hunter biden and teresa heinz kerry's
stepson christopher biden founded
something called rosemont seneca
partners they were in the chinese deal
that hunter promised to hold 10 percent
for the big guy so the heinz and the
bidens once again they're colluding on a
massive scale with the chinese and
nobody's screaming conflict of interest
here i imagine gee and the chinese are
loving this look john kerry was the guy
who negotiated the prison release the
iran cash deal you know he gave uh 1.7
billion dollars to the mullahs what did
we get for that not very much and it
looks like he's on path to do the same
with china vis-a-vis the climate xi is
smiling from ear to coal emitting ear
raymond you win the prize for six
degrees of hunter biden i did not know
that but
uh well done but you i did my research
you do you always do which we appreciate
so sure this idea and i asked the same
thing to vivek because i think it's
important
when we're negotiating over something
that we care a lot about because the
left is obsessed with climate change and
our adversaries know they don't care
about it at all and they can exploit
that situation
they do the happy dance because they can
give away
little concessions on a meaningless
topic and then do whatever they want
elsewhere in the world
well we heard it today from biden you
hear it from john kerry and nancy pelosi
last week in the uk said the same thing
they say oh well the uyghurs are being
put in internment camps in china
religion is being suppressed free speech
is demolished by china but look the
overarching and more important thing for
us is to negotiate a climate change deal
well the chinese love that math because
they get to trade all their horrible
trade abuses and the inequities in our
trade imbalances as well as their human
rights record away for some bs climate
change pact the chinese are not reliable
partners pete they lied to their own
people about free speech they crushed
hong kong they promised 50 years of no
change in hong kong guess what they lied
and putting john kerry in charge of
climate change the the the emissions the
toxic emission i most worry about is
what comes out of john kerry's mouth
that private plane that he he's
defending a moment ago
30 times the emission of a normal
private plane he's already blown and
we're only in september this is like
making mitt romney the u.s pet care czar
or bill clinton the you know protect the
innocence of young women czar i mean
john kerry has no credibility when it
comes to the climate or very much else
raymond arroyo as you always do you
deliver sir thank you very much
appreciate it well my friend hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else